last audience question of 2018 David
religion is a disaster religion is
damaging how can we make religion
illegal this is a bad idea okay number
one we probably can't make religion
illegal first of all because it's sort
of enshrined in our Constitution
secondly because how do you police what
is in someone's mind which is where
religion exists whether or not you're
going to church you can still be
religious in your mind but this this
doesn't make any sense oh okay so I
don't think that this is a big topic on
on the left trying to make religion
illegal but to be abundantly clear
trying to make religion illegal is a
losing issue legally it's a losing issue
constitutionally it's a losing issue
politically if you aren't religious and
you don't like religion you think that
organized religion is problematic in
many ways which I do then make the focus
secularism right which means separation
of church and state making sure that
religion is not influencing civil
government and that when we figure out
well what should be legal in terms of
abortion or gay marriage or stem-cell
research we make those decisions based
on science and empiricism and the
material world rather than because of
religious beliefs which are a
self-professed
and arbitrary okay make that the focus
that's all great I'm with you trying to
make religion illegal is a horrible idea
it is self sabotage it would never work
and any candidate who runs on anything
even approximating this idea and I know
most people in the audience know this is
setting themselves up to fail and is
setting up the left assuming it's a
left-wing candidate who proposes this
although I don't see anyone proposing it
to hurt the left so I don't know exactly
the sort of source of this question it
just came in from the audience but this
is a terrible idea it would never work
don't do it and on that note I will tell
you that on today's bonus show the last
bonus show of 2018 we will talk about
the government shutdown continuing
likely to stretch into
20-19 we will talk about an incredible
electronic electric transformer
explosion that took place in New York
which turned the entire skyline blue
even reported on on the news in my birth
country of Argentina I turned on the
news from Argentina this morning they
were talking about this stunning video
out of New York and very interestingly
in the world of the fake news battles
MSNBC's ratings have topped fox news for
the first time in 18 years what does it
mean should we care what should we make
of it in the world of independent media
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get access by becoming a
member at join pakman.com by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and most recently option number 3
by becoming a youtube member by clicking
the blue join button on our youtube
channel or on any one of our youtube
videos talk to you on the bonus show if
you have access if not I will speak to
you in the New Year